hello and welcome to the newer review
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with more
jiu jitsu wonder
this time to examine a cursed woman and
actually i did get a little bit beyond
that
because quite frankly the way things
ended were a bit too sudden
and i'm really glad i did mostly because
of panda
that's very much all i ever need to see
to sell me on just about anything
there's a talking panda sorcerer
sure this is immediately the best thing
i have ever read so if you want to see
more jude's content both the panda and i
would implore you to press the subscribe
button for the new world review which
will allow me to curse you with regular
jiu-jitsu guys and content uploaded
straight into your youtube feed but as
we are still in the introductory phase
of the series the premise of this
arc is still fairly simple bad things
are happening at a bad place and so
we've called in our three first year
juju to students to deal with it one of
which still has really no knowledge of
how to use curse power
at all fairly standard shown and set up
i suppose but with some very nice
intrigue added towards the end
discovering that this was all
effectively a setup to kill yuji and
very potentially our other two first
years as well which i quite like is an
overall idea because generally it
usually feels really contrived to get
the inexperienced protagonist involved
in a situation well out of their league
but akutami has engineered this rather
well
and of course rather morbidly but the
first few pages of this arc swiftly
smack me in the face with something i
both love and something that i love a
lot less one may even say strongly
dislike and this has to do with the
whole curse grading system so if any of
you followed my black clover review
videos and you'll be well aware that i
love and crave structure with power
systems and that is certainly what we've
given here it's always interesting to
delve into any form of ranking system
and having five grades of curses to work
with
seemed good in theory however i do think
that we may have immediately ruined that
setup by skipping straight to the top
and dealing with a special great curse
which to be fair i suppose is the entire
idea
stuff like this generally gets brought
up as a way of inflating drama setting
up a hierarchy so that we as the
audience feel that moment of
oh [ __ ] when we cut straight to the top
it does verge on making the system
itself slightly redundant though because
that's four levels of probably nothing
and the arc is also resolved with the
whole idea that the special grade is
meaningless due to the vast difference
between sukuna and
the uh the insect that's plenty of
complaining though because other than
that things were pretty damn strong
during the sarc and having brought him
up let's begin with the man of the hour
real men sukuna and the moment where he
took over yuji's body was pretty
phenomenal entirely expected due to the
nature of their shared existence but i
have to say that there is just something
so wonderfully warped about seeing
sukuna's personality manifest with
anuji's body especially as we get to
know suka no more but watching this kid
whose only real mantra in life is to
help people being taken over by a
presence that exists to ensure the exact
opposite
and not only that but having such a damn
sadistic smile as well both cool
and terrifying well all together it's
quite something and it's also just
interesting to watch this struggle begin
sukuna a powerful man
maybe he's not a man who's here i don't
know what he is but he's obsessed with
attaining life versus yuji a relatively
powerless boy resigned to death and on
paper that should really not be a good
combination the desire to live should
win out every time but with the
exception that yuji is determined to die
on his own terms which means ridding the
world of tsukuna and that's just great
the crazy balancing act to pull off that
will lead both of them to a lot of
incidental cooperation as it did during
the suck another interesting thing to
note about yuji in particular though is
that he isn't anywhere near as flat of a
character as he may have originally
seemed he basically gave me exactly what
i wanted from a continuation
and what i mean by this is that i'm sure
you know the whole classic protagonist
trope of the insanely driven young boy
who never gives up
no matter what the thing is well
something quite pleasantly surprising
about yuji in this arc is that he has a
pretty extreme inner conflict tossing up
his ideas of pain and fear versus his
mission to quote help everyone there's
this very genuine struggle of self and
it makes yugi far more relatable and i
would say
far more human there is this side to him
that simply isn't
cool if you will which if anything makes
his ultimate resolve that much more
impressive and speaking of that actually
leads us into the cliffhanger of the
previous arc actually where it was
stated that one of our precious first
years would die and as suspected
it was eugene although i'm nowhere near
as annoyed with this as i thought i
might be given the scenario that was set
up i do think that yuji's decision to
sacrifice himself was very well made
although i'll reserve for judgement
until his inevitable revival has been
completed because usually i despise
using death or a death scene in any
series where the character is later
revealed to be alive or revived but
jiujitsukai sin lands in a very
interesting area given that the major
motif of the series at this point is
death it actually becomes far more
natural and more welcome to delve into
it because i suppose a big problem with
death is that usually if it's used well
within a story
there's actually surprisingly little to
explore all you have are the lingering
effects of death on those left behind
but it looks like yuji is about to
confront this concept in a more
head-on manner which is quite exciting
and that is where i left off by the way
i got to the end of chapter 10 which is
yugi smack talking sukuna in the very um
corpsey realm and i'm quite excited to
see where that goes but our other
major focus of this arc would be
fushiguru and rather wonderfully i got a
bit of what i was looking for last week
with some personality expansion and in
fact i got a bit more than what i
bargained for because we've got some
pretty big questions coming from his
general direction
such as who's to say someone you save
won't kill someone in the future as well
as the whole theoretical concept that
karma doesn't happen on its own it's a
more active process
at least according to fushiguru all of
which is quite fascinating because of
course most of his philosophy is very
much at odds with his decision to save
yuji in the first time something that is
resolved via epiphany of just wanting to
save yuji because he's a good person
regardless of the world ending evil
residing within him so fushiguro is
actually a bit of a complicated guy with
a clear sense of his own moral values i
did notice that he didn't come to the
conclusion of wanting to help everyone
though as yuji does his personality
didn't actually change as a result of
this arc which is fascinating and he
still wishes to help only those whom he
deems good which sounds like it could
lead to some fun potential conflict in
the future there was also some potential
seeding for his father as well like
there was this whole weird line that
went something like well my father
didn't even know my gender but he's
still alive
out there somewhere a latter of which
honestly seems like a pretty pointless
thing to say unless he's going to appear
at some stage in the future
such family drama i'm also quite
enamored by his abilities to create
doggos froggos and even a bigger mask
bird although i am annoyed that the
white dog got destroyed he was
such a good boy although i suspected
that may happen when akutami made a
point of focusing on how cute it was
because that is the moment where i
suddenly remembered what it is i was
reading and the good things have a habit
of turning bad pretty quickly in jujutsu
kaisen which speaking of i do quite like
the continued use of shia horror to
great effect it's nice to have that
mechanism to immediately flip a switch
which in this case would be something
like encountering a bunch of bodies all
shmushed into balls or the incredible
ease by which yuji just up and lost a
hand
and along with all of this comes
morbidity as well like the idea that we
immediately found that lady's son
dead within a few pages because in a
more typical series the idea would have
been to save that son
and really embody that yuji mantra of
helping people with some sort of grand
act but here we have
more of a bitter dose of reality and i
like that yuji then has to think
well what's the best way to help that
lady now and he lands on the idea of
returning her son's body to her which is
such an incredibly depressing thought
but that's just the territory
this series comes with and it's starting
to make me wonder if jujutsu kaisen
might have been better served as a
senior manga and really allowed to push
some of the boundaries that we really
can't touch in a shonen series although
with that said i do think the series is
doing a pretty damn good job straddling
these lines thus far and i only hope
that it continues to dive deeper now
because i also read one chapter further
than the actual arc i was also
introduced to what looks like our first
set of primary antagonists that are not
tsukuna
and yes sure i have to give akutami all
the credit in the world for being bold
enough to create a volcano headed
cyclops that guy
that thing that curse whatever it is
it's eye-catching
fun intended in fact i don't really
remember any of the other curse spirit
being things that appeared alongside mr
happy face because the cyclops was just
so attention-grabbing not that that's a
bad thing though in fact rather
unexpectedly we even had a bit of a
sit-down chat with cyclops san where he
unveiled an interesting counter
philosophy the whole concept that curses
are actually humanity's purest form and
what inhabits this world as we speak
of these lying facades of humankind and
i really like that as an antagonistic
motivating thought much better than your
classic qualcomm more powerful than you
so this world should be mine kind of
crap in jiu jitsu guy said it actually
seems like there's more of a core belief
to be grappled with because as far as
i'm aware the cyclops
well he's not exactly wrong is he the
curses aren't aberrations of the world
they're more of just
natural evolution are they not and i
don't know but are we eventually going
to have to grapple with the idea that
perhaps curses have just as much right
to exist
as the humans that spawn them no idea
but i do like that these sorts of ideas
are being brought up at such an early
stage it makes me much more intrigued to
see more of these antagonists as soon as
possible please
and similarly we have also expanded into
a batch of new students one of which
is the aforementioned panda and in all
seriousness pandas are by far my
favorite animal so this is very welcome
news
i really don't care how we're talking
panda exists or why it might be a mighty
curse sorcerer none of it matters all i
know is that jujutsu kaisen has gone
from like a seven to a ten all due to
panda propaganda and two other students
were also introduced i don't have any
strong comment on them at this time but
they did also seem to come with the
reminder that jude kaisen is for all of
its cursed horror also
a high school series with an upcoming
enter high event against
another jujutsu school a jujutsu battle
where the only rule
is no killing which well that should be
fun but actually do you know what the
worst part about this five chapters was
not enough gojo in fact in the actual
coast wilmark there were like zero units
of gojo so it was very welcome to see
him in the chapter immediately following
it especially with the continued hype
surrounding him he was even identified
by smiley villain guy as absolutely
essential to get rid of so i cannot wait
to see him in action if every character
in the series
thus far i would say that he and sukuna
are the only ones that truly hit me with
their raw presence when gojo is in a
panel you better believe i'm paying
attention but someone who i definitely
wasn't paying attention to though was
kugasaki she definitely had a very
light arc and i was hoping for some more
fushigura style substance coming from
her general direction considering that
she was very much thrown in at the last
second during the introduction
but just as with fushigura i can only
assume that her time is coming but all
around this was a very solid
continuation for jiu-jitsu kaiser a nice
small arc that explores some shockingly
deep concepts in some very blunt ways
setting up a ton of great intrigue and i
cannot wait to dive into more and that
pretty much does it for this blind
review of the cursed woo mark of
jujutsukai sen and what do you guys
think please leave your thoughts in the
comments below or even join my discord
server and if you're keen for some more
introduce to sorcery then please do
check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel
for very maybe regular jujutsu kaisen
morbidity delivered straight into your
youtube feed but for now this has been
the new world review and i'll see you
next time